global energy prices are rising
businesses are at breaking point the
system is overheating
ministers say green energy sources are
the answer but that takes time and needs
investment the answer right now the
british chambers of commerce say is an
energy price cap to help companies cope
with the cost
claire walker the co-executive director
of the british chambers of commerce said
there is a clear case to create an sme
energy price cap and protecting smaller
firms from some of the price increases
they would otherwise face
if the government doesn't step in some
factories may have to close and that
could impact us all we had a meeting
with the secretary of state on friday
and we made it very clear to him that we
were looking for action in the days and
weeks to come these are unprecedentedly
high and unprecedentedly rapidly
changing gas prices and what we're
seeking is
some support from government over this
very very tight winter period and if
that doesn't happen sadly i fear that
there'll be more businesses that find
themselves unable to operate in the
coming weeks and months
and that will be felt uh as a knock-on
effect across supply chains as a whole
and i think that could have effects on
the shoppers yeah what the consumers can
see in the shops here in westminster the
focus is already shifting to cop26 to
talk of reducing carbon emissions the
government hopes global energy prices
will stabilize they don't want to be
subsidising gas but long and short-term
ambitions are colliding here and there's
a concern that it's consumers who will
lose out families and businesses across
the country are concerned and they have
a right also to be
very angry because what we're seeing is
chaos after chaos crisis after crisis
whether that has been food prices and
food shortages over the summer with
nando's and iceland and
mcdonald's whether that's been the flu
jabs that were delayed and now we're
seeing businesses starting to say that
they might be priced out of of
production
ministers may hope businesses can ride
out this choppy period and maybe some
can for now but not all and not forever
boris johnson wants us all to cut
emissions
but with so much pressure on costs right
now that ambition is getting squeezed
further and further out of focus kate
mccann sky news